these students come from Nigeria now
they are living together in Benin as
students at the West African Union
University theodore wu Babalola and his
classmates this will be home for the
next few years back in Nigeria their
chances of getting into University was
slim I'm all gotcha it was very
astonished casual really expecting what
we saw you didn't even in fact it was
your first year and we have something
that even in two years time we still
keep enjoying it the university is only
a couple of streets away in an uni
developed area today economics is on the
schedule for lecturer Emily a heater the
class is about teaching the fundamentals
and making the students believe in
themselves it's just getting them to
understand why you want them why you
want where I want them to start thinking
that they could be leaders of tomorrow
leaders in Africa once that is passed on
to them I think it's easier you know
nineteen-year-old edo rule has taken
that message on board I can change the
whole economy of Nigeria even I'll take
it goodbye even around the world so my
main goal of talk international issues
or even coming here is to become a great
personal life a profession dance I
messer can't even imagine that oh I can
be this kind of British
because I want to take it global
politics in Nigeria corruption a beef I
can do it benin native diode or whose na
is studying medicine she is one of
nearly 70 students signed up to study
here my aim is to progress and to see
which steps we have to take in order to
improve the health system and to raise
the standard of living the 17 year old
has a chemistry exam and she's
determined to pass every third student
here gets a scholarship the rest pay
tuition fees of around a thousand euros
per semester a DME Bishop is the
president of the University he wants to
make access to education as open as
possible West African university has
musically decided to have a system where
we create a better orientation a better
teaching a better service delivery where
we can not do students putting into them
the mindset that ultimately have been
the big behind the problem in Africa
toyoda lives in benning's business
center kitano she spends her free time
studying for her course her father is a
doctor and he's paying for her studies
theodis family is proud of her ambition
they hope that one day she'll become one
of many young African leaders